let us begin I don't know any Italian
how do you say let's do it opposites of
ciao welcome to the series premiere of
edible history we're learning the
stories behind some of the world's most
popular foods then diving into the
kitchen to try our hand at cooking like
the chefs and bakers of yesteryear today
we're going to be discussing the origins
of an often loved and heartburn inducing
dish called lasagna ah lasagna it's
tasty it's filling it's dense but where
does the Sania come from Italy probably
why is it like this has it always been
so dense
have people ever eaten it and then not
immediately taking a nap these are all
questions and I'm seeking answers today
we're joined by Linda from salty Seattle
hello what's up can you tell me a little
bit about lasagna where it comes from so
this is actually super interesting
Italy's very regionalist everybody
thinks they invented and they both sort
of like five four the inventor of what
we think of as modern-day
Hassan yeah but the reality is it
predates both of those different
versions this poem that dates all the
way back to the 13th century he who
looks at magnitude is often mistaken a
grain of pepper conquers lasagna with
its strength so that comes all the way
back from the 1200s which probably
predates anything anybody was doing in
Sicily or
in Bologna wow that's super old was it
always as as cheesy and a saucy as it is
today definitely not the Chinese didn't
even get tomatoes until like the latter
Renaissance what I think of tomatoes is
basically an Italian fruit the original
lasagnas were basically dry cracky
sheets with maybe a little bit of like a
sprinkling or a smattering of some
cheese and then maybe like some some
strange and esoteric medieval spices
when I think about lasagna I picture a
big
serving tray of lasagna and everybody's
getting their own individual slice
earlier iterations of lasagna they would
make like little like pasta
handkerchiefs little just squares you
know in a square and then maybe some
bechamel oh one of the original sauces
and then another square and then
Sebastian Mela they would actually eat
it off of hot Spears or hot sticks I got
to say that a boiled semi spiced noodle
on a hot stick is not what I think of
when I think of lasagna today we'll be
making a lasagna recipe that's seven
hundred years old it comes from the
libéré de Coquina an anonymous cookbook
from the 14th century court of Naples
Wow now as Linda told us this won't end
up looking anything like the lasagna we
know and love in fact the only
ingredients of the recipe calls for art
semolina flour water cheese and medieval
spices like cardamom clove and cinnamon
I've never thought of adding those to my
lasagna never even once so to begin
let's make our dough semolina flour plus
water equals dough for me to eat to make
my pasta I'm gonna start by dumping out
my semolina flour and making a well and
then using our finger we're gonna make
it deeper nice now we're gonna pour some
water into this well and then start to
gently stir it together we're gonna add
a little more water
[Music]
oh yeah baby
semolina I barely know uh it feels a
little granular and it's still falling
apart at the edges so just keep kneading
until it becomes nice and smooth and
then when you poke it it springs back at
you you know you can really feel this up
in your wrist which is probably why
Italian grandmas have such strong hands
okay we're gonna put it in a little ball
now this is looking pretty smooth to me
now we just got to give it a little poke
and see if it springs back at us a bloom
so we're done with our dough now we just
have to let it rest for 30 minutes good
night little dough when you wake up
things are gonna get weird
Oh wha ah well what a well-rested dough
now I'm gonna roll it out basically as
flat as I can
sorry reflex we're gonna sprinkle a
little flour on to make sure it doesn't
stick
[Music]
Wow it's gonna take a minute to get this
thing flat do this this is a pro move on
if you guys have ever seen it it's
called al my hands hurt
[Music]
okay that looks pretty good let's check
and it's not been enough we can get
thinner than this let's go so my cutting
board is a little bit too small for that
depth and width I want to roll out so
I'm actually just gonna trim some of the
edges and set the rest aside great now
let's just keep on rolling
[Music]
all right let's take a look oh this this
is looking like pasta this looks pretty
dang thing to me and it feels so good
it's so fun to hold it's like holding
flesh the next step is to cut our pasta
into squares three fingers long and wide
because it's a square now I was pretty
hesitant when it said cut it into
squares because is it lasagna like a
rectangle but that's what the Latin said
to do it's all Greek to me
oh shoot
I haven't measured
I'm sure you've noticed by now rabid
edible history fans but this is not your
standard tasty fare okay and that's not
them that's me these lines look plenty
straight you got our squares cut and
ready to go so next step is to boil them
patience is a virtue we're gonna take
our little pasta squares and boil them
in salted water for about two to three
minutes apiece now I'm just gonna take
out my tiny squares and set them aside
to cool before I add all of my tasty
goodness I am genuinely curious about
how this is gonna work out okay here we
are the homestretch so now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take our
individual squares layer them with
cheese add some spices and just keep
going until we feel like stopping or we
run out too we'll be using goat cheese
we're also gonna be adding a little
parmesan because it's my show we can do
whatever we want and also a little v to
add let's see how these all taste
together now we're gonna add a little
layer of clove and then place on top
because the steps are so vague I'm gonna
add one spice at a time instead of
putting all the spices on every layer
ooh Lala it's looking like lasagna
already
[Music]
[Music]
voila now looking at this I'm going to
take a little bit artistic liberty and
maybe just put a gentle sprinkle of feta
and parmesan over it little feta makes
it better
I'm very rustic with my plating you know
gives it a little bit of that should I
say quack and last but not least we'll
eat it exactly as the recipe tells us it
says with a wooden stick
okay so buon appetito this is pretty
neato so I guess I don't I don't really
know how if I'm supposed to flip it
upside down and eat it yeah okay Wow
I mean let's be honest the wooden stick
really works it pretty much holds it all
together Cheers
you know I don't know if I need this
wooden stick but this is not bad
mine tastes like arugula like a cheesy
noodley cinnamon cardamom eat clovie
dessert it's not the most balanced array
of spices but honestly I feel like with
time with practice this could turn out
pretty good I would definitely want to
bake it though I think that would just
make it so much better despite them
looking and tasting so different I can
really see how this later evolved to
becoming what we consider lasagna it
goes to show that no matter how far back
you go in time some dishes are just good
hmm I kind of dig it who'd have thunk
what a tasty little thing thanks so much
for watching this episode of edible
history I for one I'm excited to see
where our taste buds take us next
you
[Music]